morning approximately 5 a.m was bombed
by
russian troops uh on our international
peacekeeping center
uh so it's all over the world known
center because
a lot of militaries all over the world
they have like a trainings a long years
before and so they have training there
so it was it was right now it's used for
for our ukrainian military but it's all
over the world known and so it's like
like it was highly equipped and so a lot
of a lot of buildings and so it was uh
attacked by russians and so it's very
sad news that officially uh regional
military administration
gave information that
35 hour ukrainians who were killed
militaries 35
yeah and so more than more than 100 were
injured
again the whole the whole ukraine they
called for foreclose the sky because it
can save a lot of lives and even that
that who that that this morning uh were
killed so it also uh again new signal in
order that have to be closed because so
it's uh
we have to also emphasize that
that's uh putin so can he can use
nuclear weapon because if he bombed uh
and killed russian troops on peaceful
cities children a woman they bombed uh
children hospital so they can do
everything in the whole world right now
have to be engaged how to solve this
problem
the
if they strike in poland what happens
well look we take our article 5
commitment very seriously and the vice
president was uh was pretty firm about
that on a recent visit so has been
secretary austin uh an armed attack
against one is considered an armed
attack against all that is why martha we
continue to flow and to move and to
reposition forces and capabilities along
nato's eastern flank to make sure that
we can defend every inch of nato
territory if we need to now there's no
reason we should need to uh because
there's no reason that there should be
war in ukraine as it is and we've made
it very clear to russia that nato
territory will be defended not just by
the united states but by our allies we
have a deconfliction uh uh mechanism set
up so that we can get we can talk to the
russian ministry of defense that system
is working that line is working uh and
we will absolutely not hesitate to use
it if we need to